britney spears and her fiance sam askari
have their eyes on the prize that is
true a source tells et the engaged pair
is very career focused right now
especially sam and adds that he's really
pursuing all opportunities coming his
way and wants to amp up his persona they
are both going so hard right now and
putting in a lot of work and effort into
all areas of their lives both personally
and professionally
[Music]
of course back in november a los angeles
judge ruled to terminate the
conservatorship that controlled brits
life career and finances for 13 years
what's next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person
brittany
and someone who's really been a
motivating factor in the latest chapter
sam i'm just living my life right now
the source adds sam's drive and ambition
is empowering brittany to keep moving
and pursue her dreams as well she
doesn't want to have a partner who is
just fine being quiet and sitting on the
sidelines she is equally as motivated
and career driven as he is that's their
focus and the path they are on right now
she's doing great i'm great i'm just
it's the happiest time of our lives and
we're just enjoying it and there's no
doubt britt is ready for a comeback amid
multiple reports that the pop star has
signed a 15 million tell-all book deal
with simon and schuster which echoes
what a source told et in december that
britney is actively eyeing different
brand deals and entertainment
opportunities quote she's excited to put
her business woman hat on in the new
year and explore different ventures that
weren't available to her in the past
brittany is her own decision maker now
the main thing is to enjoy life
and take today take one day at a time
and i try to live by that and the grammy
winner seems to be doing just that since
getting her freedom back and not letting
family drama get in the way in fact
brittany and sam recently took a trip to
hawaii to decompress from the feud with
her sister jamie lynn following the
release of her memoir things i should
have said i think that
it's a healing process that
i know that i'm working through i can't
speak for anyone else because
each of us are in this family and we all
are dealing with things individually and
from our own
point of view so i think we have to
respect each other's process as we go
through it but it's in real time
brit reacted to the book and jamie
lynn's promotional interviews in a
series of expletive-filled and
since-deleted social media posts at the
time of the singer's tropical getaway
the source told et brittany felt
overwhelmed and needed an escape
brittany and sam are both trying to
focus on the good in their lives and
stay positive but jamie lynn's interview
really upset both of them adding that
the couple really loves their alone time
and feels most at peace in hawaii it's
their sacred place as a couple it's
amazing it's heaven from here on out
careers aside it seems the pair is also
carving out time to plan their dream
nuptials here's what sam told e.t in
november what kind of wedding do you
want to have what's your dream day you
know it's up to her she's wearing the
pants now
[Music]